the findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment is proud
to work with saint jude's ranch for
children jc fernandez stopped in to
learn more about the incredible things
they're doing for foster children take a
look
[Music]
well here we are at st jude's ranch for
children and we're with our good friend
it's tyler quarter he's the cfo of the
findlay automotive group it's great to
see you buddy it's great to see you jc
welcome to beautiful boulder city and st
judran this is my first time here and
i'm excited to kind of get a tour but
tell us first why did you guys decide to
get involved with st huge ranch well i
mean it's a wonderful cause they take
care of neglected and abused children
and so i mean who couldn't get behind
that so we've been doing some volunteer
work out here with our employees in fact
if you uh look around on the campus here
the christmas decorations we were out
here a few weeks ago doing all that i
actually did some physical labor and
decorated some of those trees it's very
festive i noticed all the lights it
looked fantastic so it's a wonderful
cause i got a beautiful campus here and
uh it's good to have you here can you
show me around yeah absolutely so what
i'm going to do is let's go meet
christina who's the executive director
here and she can tell you all about what
they do
hi
christina welcome come on in come on in
let's check out come on we're so excited
to have you welcome to one of our
amazing homes so this is one of the
homes that actual children and one of
the caretakers live in yeah there's a
house parent here that lives this is her
home and kids will come and live here
and it's really a place of hope and
healing it's very inviting inside here
can you give us a little tour sure
absolutely let's check out one of the
rooms perfect he has some good shows
we've got a nice bookshelf absolutely
and
in this room
in this room is for two children so when
new kids get here this will be for two
girls they'll get to decorate their room
and they'll get clothing and all the
things that they need to make this a
warm and comfortable place while they
live with us and it's more than just
foster care that you do do you also have
job placement as well yep we have a job
training program on campus for our
teenagers and we actually have an
incredible thrift store that i think we
should go check out christina this is
one packed thrift store how does this
whole situation work no it's so
beautiful in here well you know our
community donates to us and we pick up
donations from lots of community
supporters and it's open to the public
and proceeds from the thrift store go
where yes 100 of what we sell in the
store supports our programs and we're so
grateful it's also a job training
program so a lot of the teenagers that
live here on our boulder city campus
they need job skills they need to earn a
paycheck and you know start getting
those skills and so they're able to work
here in the store doing customer service
attending to clients you know helping
price items and so it's a win-win
situation and if someone's watching
right now i know i got a closet full of
stuff i want to get rid of how do i how
do i donate how does the donation
process work yeah probably the easiest
way is to visit on our website at
studentsranch.org there's some
information there there's a phone number
we can help either coordinate to pick up
or people can come and drop it off to us
and i know after watching today there's
got to be people watching that want to
volunteer their time do you accept
volunteer time absolutely we need
volunteers to help us all over this
campus including in the store so there
is room for everybody to help us here at
st juice ranch for children well tyler
we thank you and christina thank you so
much the holidays are upon us i might do
some shopping if that's okay with
everybody all right thank you so much i
appreciate it thank you so much thank
you to findlay automotive for sponsoring
this segment this week findlay toyota
will be accepting new unwrapped toys for
st jude ranch so if you donate you
receive 20 off your service ticket